The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: Welcome back.
We're now going get in the demo
portion of lecture zero three.
And so these demos are
in the program directory,
and the examples.
We've now moved on
from kind of the intro
in to the
applications, and we're
going to do this when we're
dealing with entities extracted
from this data set.
So we go in to the entity
analysis directory.
Start my shell here, so.
Start our MATLAB session here.
I always run MATLAB
from the shell.
If you prefer to run it
from the ID, that's fine.
And again, our D4M code runs in
a variety of environments, not
just MATLAB.
Right.
That's started up here, so
let's-- before we do that,
let's look at our data set here.
So this is a nice
little data set.
It's about 2.4
megabytes of data.
And some of the
Reuters documents
processed through
our entity extractor
here at Lincoln Laboratory.
And so if I look at this, say
with Microsoft Excel, try that.
All right, so you can see
that pretty clearly, right?
So we basically just have a
row, key here to read this in.
We have a document column,
which is the actual--
so we widen that.
That's the actual document
that it appears in.
We have the entity, happen
to be alphabetical here,
the way it comes out.
We have the word
position in the document,
so this tells you that
this entity appeared
in these positions
in this document.
And then various types--
location, person, organization,
those types of things.
So that's what we extracted
from these documents.
There's no verbs here.
We just tell you a person,
a place, an organization,
appeared in this document.
It wouldn't say thing
about what they're doing,
or anything like that.
So.
But this just shows an
example of the kind of data
that we have here.
So.
There's that.
To save.
So, all right.
So the first thing
we're going to do,
is the first script,
is entity analysis one.
We're going to read the data in.
All right, there we go.
So-- and this first
line just reads this in.
We have-- it's a
fair amount of data.
We're turning it all in
to an associative array.
We have actually some faster
parsers that will read it in.
You know, but just
the read CSV is
kind of the most general
purpose one that's fairly nice.
So it's going to go,
and we'll go back.
It's running about a
whole bunch of stuff here.
It tries to pull
together its graphics.
All right.
So let's take a look
at what we did here.
So we read in the data into,
essentially an edge list,
associative array.
Just display the first few
rows here so you can see.
So it's alphabetized.
The lexigraph we sorted
the first columns, always
something to be aware of.
That 1 is then followed by
10, is then followed by 100
and then 1,000 in this sorting.
Here's the documents,
here's the entity.
There's the positions.
So it just looks like the
normal table that we read in,
but it is an associative array.
Now I'm going to want
to sort of pull this
into our exploded schema.
And this table
didn't necessarily
come to us in the easiest
format to do that in.
So there's a few tricks
that we have to do.
So we're going to go and get
each document, basically.
So we have a row, a column and
the doc, so that's the value.
So this is-- whenever you do a
query in an associative array,
one of the powerful things
about MATLAB is you can change,
you can have variable
numbers of output arguments.
And you can change the behavior.
So if I just wanted this to
return-- if I set this to,
a equals e this, I
would have just gotten
an associative array vector.
But if I give it three
output arguments, so say,
I'll give you the triples that
went into constructing that.
Because sometimes that's
what you want to do.
Also it's faster,
because to do this
every time I do a sub
associative array,
I effectively have to
pull out the triples,
and then reconstitute
the associative array.
And that could take some time.
It just saves you a step.
It goes directly to the triple
switches, which is nice.
So I basically say, give
me the document column,
give me the entity column,
give me the position column.
Now I have all these.
And since I know
they're dense, I
know that these
are all lined up.
The first doc string,
and entity string,
and position string,
and type string
are all-- so that's me
exploiting a little bit.
I know this is a dense
table and I'm not
going have any missing there.
Now I'm going to interleave
the type and entity strings.
So I have this function
called Cat String.
So basically Cat String
takes one string list
and another string
list, and then it
leaves them with a separator,
a single character separator.
And now I can construct a
new sparse matrix, which
has docks for the row key.
This new thing called type
entity, to be the columns,
and I'll just throw the
position in as the value.
And so that is our
exploded schema
that we just talked about.
Done for us in a couple lines.
There's other functions
they do that as well.
And since I don't
want to repeat this,
because it took a little
while to read it in.
I'm just going to save
it as a MATLAB of binary,
which will then read in
very quickly from now on.
Which is nice.
So I can save it.
There you go.
Just to show you, if I
show you the first entry
here, in the row.
And then, this
just shows you this
is the different
types of columns
that were in that data set.
So this the row key here.
And the various columns.
These are the different columns.
And then it shows you how
many-- the locations of that
word there.
If I display it, I
see that I ended up
creating an associative array.
And it consisted of almost
10,000 unique documents.
And 3,657 unique entities
in that data set.
And then we're going
to take a look at that.
We can do spy and transpose.
If we look at here,
zoom in on that.
You can see different
types of structures here.
Click on one of them.
And that tells us that
the location Singapore
appeared in this document
in these two word positions.
So.
That's typically
about how many lines
it takes to take essentially
a basic CSV file,
and cast it into the
associative array to start doing
start doing real work.
That's typically what we see.
If you find it's getting
a lot longer than that,
then that probably
means there's a trick
that you're not quite getting.
And there again, we're
always happy to help people
do this very important step.
This first-- taking your data
and getting into this format
so that you can do
subsequent analysis on it.
All right.
So there's that.
Let's go on to the
next sample here.
So we're going to do
some statistics on this.
See, that took a lot
less time loading it
in from a binary
much, much faster.
Much, much faster.
Very fast.
I mean, faster than if
you put in a database
and read it out of a database.
Much faster to read a file.
So we always encourage
people to do that.
This just gets
displaced the size.
So we have-- that's what we
had in the original data.
nnz shows the number of entries.
So we do nnz, that's
the number of entries.
All right.
I now want to undo
what I did before.
I want to convert it
back into a dense table.
I want to take all those
values, and convert--
I want to take all those things
that [INAUDIBLE] because I just
want to count how many, I want
to know how many locations
organization people have.
So we have this function
here called call-to-type.
And another function that I
forget the precise name that
does the reverse,
which basically give me
an associative array.
Give me a delimiter
for the columns,
and I'm going to now
rip that back apart.
Stick that back into
the value position,
and then you're going to
now sort of essentially
make it dense again.
And so we do that.
We then throw away
the actual values.
And so we do this
double [INAUDIBLE],
which converts it all to ones,
and then we can sum the rows.
So we collapsed along rows.
Now we have count.
It tells me in this data
set I have 9,600 locations,
organizations, people, time.
Those are the
distinct ones there.
All right.
Let's see we can
count each entity.
So we have our thing here.
We just do a count.
We can find the triples-- so
basically I've just done a sum.
So this is the original,
exploded scheme.
I basically summed
all the rows together.
So now we're getting a count
for each unique entity.
And I can find-- instead if one
another way to get the triple
is just to pass, use
the find command.
Works the same way
as it does in MATLAB.
It will now give you
a set up of triples.
A temp, which we don't
really care about,
because we've collapsed that
dimensional to be all ones.
The actual entity and the count.
And I'm going to create a new
associative matrix out of that.
So we now have the
counts and the entity.
And I'm going to plot
a histogram of that.
So I'm going to go
with my count things.
I'm just going to dip the
locations out of that.
So using that
Starts With command,
I say get me all locations.
I'm now going to just real
map, and I say give me
the adjacency matrix, which
is return to regular sparse
matrix.
I can do sum, full, log, log.
Now this is the classic
degree distribution
of all the locations
in this data.
And it shows us that certain
locations are very common.
A few of them are very common.
And a few locate, as they
appear in most of the documents,
and a lot of locations only
appear in one document.
So this is the classical--
we call power law-- degree
distribution.
Again, always a
good thing to check.
Sometimes you can't do
this on the full data set,
it's so large.
But just even a sample,
just to sort of-- you
want to know this
from the beginning.
Am I dealing with something
that looks like a power law?
So like everything else--
or oh, what do you know,
I see a big spike here.
Well what's that about?
Or it looks like a bell curve.
Or something like that.
And so this is just really
computing means, good.
Computing basic
histograms, very good.
Without this basic
information, it's really hard
to advance in detection theory.
And so-- and this
is probably where
we take a slightly different
philosophical approach
than a lot of the data
mining community, which
tends to focus on just finding
stuff that's interesting.
Where we tend to focus on
understanding the data,
modeling the data,
coming up with models
for what we're trying to
find, and then doing that.
Rather than just--
show me something
interesting in the data.
Show me a low probability
covariance or something
like that.
Which tends to be more than
the basis of the data mining
community.
Although, no doubt, I probably
offended them horribly
by simplifying it that way.
In which, case I
apologize to people
in the [INAUDIBLE] community.
But here, we-- more
traditional detection theory,
and the first thing you want
to do is get the distribution.
So you can-- typically one
thing you'll do immediately
is like you know what,
you put essentially
what we call low pass,
high pass filter on it.
Things that only appear once,
or so unique that they give us
no information, and things
that appear everywhere
again give us no
information about the data.
So you might just you have
a high pass and a low pass
filter that just
sort of eliminates
these high end and low
end types of things.
Very standard.
Signal processing technique,
that's just as relevant here
as elsewhere.
All right.
So statistics, histograms,
all good things,
easy to do in D4M on our data.
Don't be afraid
to take your data,
bump it back into
regular map of arrays,
and just do the regular things
that you would do it with
MATLAB data.
With MATLAB matrices, we
highly encourage that.
Now we're going to do the facet
algorithm that I talked about
in the lecture.
Let's do that.
So once again, we've loaded
our data in very quickly.
We've decided to
convert directly
to numeric, which is-- we're
getting rid of all those word
positions, because we don't
really care about them.
I'm going to pick-- so one thing
I like about this data set,
and for those of us
who are a little older,
we remember the
news of the 1990's.
You know?
This is all a trip to
remember [INAUDIBLE].
For those of you that
are a little younger, who
are in elementary school, this
will not mean anything to you.
But it's like-- oh yes.
A lot of stuff about the
Clinton's in this data set.
So that's always fun.
So the first facet
we're going to do
is, we want to look at
the location New York.
And the person Michael Chang.
Does anybody remember
who Michael Chang was?
Tennis player.
Yes, he was kind of like
this hip tennis player.
Used to battle
under Andre Agassi.
So, I don't know how long
his career really lasted,
but he was a very-- this is
kind of right it his peak,
I believe.
So now there is-- to show you
that equation that I showed you
in the slides wasn't a lie.
So we take our edge,
or incidence matrix,
we pick the column
New York, then
we then pick the
column, Michael Chang.
We need to do this
no call thing,
because we now have
a column vector
with a column, Michael Chang.
And a column New York.
And if we enter them
together, well they
should have no intersections.
So if we do know the no
call, it just sort of pops
those two column names away.
So now they're
effectively both one,
and we can add them
together to find
all the documents that contain
both New York and Michael
Chang.
So we do that, so we've
added them together.
This is now a new column vector.
OK.
And we transpose it to
make it a row vector.
And then when we
matrix multiply it back
against the original data set.
We just computed the histogram
of the other entities that
are in the documents they
contain both Michael Chang
and New York.
And as we can see, Michael
Chang appears three times.
That tells us there's
three documents.
And New York
appears three times.
But we also see Czech Republic,
and Austria, and Spain,
and the United States.
You want to guess
why Czech Republic?
Was Ivan Lendl
still playing then?
I'm just wandering if he had
a lot of matches against him?
Or would he already be into
[INAUDIBLE] or something
like that?
I don't know.
Probably had some Czech arch
tribal or something like that.
Or maybe there was
just a tournament
and these are the type of thing.
With the Reuters
data sets, you do
have the problem
is that the person
who types the article
always puts the location
where they filed it.
So New York could
always be in these
just because the person happens
to be based in New York,
and typed it from New York
or something like that.
So that's always fun.
We can normalize this.
So what I'm going to
do is take the facets
that we computed here, and
normalize it by their sums.
OK.
So this just-- the facet
is showing how many times
something showed up,
but it doesn't tell me
if it's like-- well is
that something that is
really common or really rare.
So now we want to look at
the places and things that
were-- we want to see, of
the other entities that
appear in these documents,
how many of them
are really, really popular?
And how many of them really just
only appear in these documents
with Michael Chang and New York.
So as you can see here-- so we
have Belarus, Czech Republic,
Virginia for some reason.
And this just shows
you-- look, these
are in a lot of--
these have a very low,
they're being divided by a
fairly large number, which
means they appear
in a lot of places.
So they happen to appear in
the same set of documents.
But they happen to appear
in a lot of documents.
As opposed to Michael
Joyce, or Virginia Wade.
That's a tennis
tournament, right?
The Virginia Wade tennis
tournament or something
like that.
These appear more
common, or more likely,
to be something that
is like, oh that's
a real sort of relation that
exists between these entities.
So that just shows
you how you do that.
Again, very powerful.
Very powerful technique.
Basic covariance type of mat, so
facets search is very powerful.
All right, so I think
we're now-- that was three,
so we are moving on to four.
So now we're going to do
some stuff with graphs.
All kinds of graphs here,
all kinds of graphs.
So once again, we loaded
in our data very quickly.
We're just going to
make a copy of it.
And then I'm going to basically
now convert the original thing
to numbers.
So get rid of those positions.
And now we're going to
do-- well so before, we
did essentially the facets of
the correlation between two
things.
But the real power of D4M is
it for about the same amount
of work, we can correlate
everything simultaneously.
So we're going to do square in,
which basically is the same as
e transpose times e.
It's a little bit faster when
we're doing self correlations,
but not too much.
You could have typed
e transpose times e.
And then we're going to
show the structure of that.
So remember we had
3,657 unique entities.
So now we've constructed
a square matrix,
it's 3,600 by 3,600
unique entities.
And we're going to plot that.
So let's see here.
So that is-- hopefully this
won't crash our computer.
So this is the
location, by location--
this is the full entity-entity
correlation matrix here.
You can see all the structure.
These are the locations.
So this block here is location
by location correlation.
This block here is
person-person correlation.
It's obviously as a dense
diagonal, it's symmetric.
And then down here are the
time-time correlations.
And so these in fact, the first
thing you'll probably notice
is these dense blocks of time
have to deal with the fact
that this is a finite
set of Reuters documents.
There's only 35
unique days, or times,
associated with the
documents themselves.
So those are showing you
the times are associated
with the-- reference.
So that would be a very--
this type of structure shows,
oh well if I want to just get
the times that were associated
with reporting, I can get that.
Or if I want to do, the
referring to some date.
And you can see
there's times that
are in the past, and future,
and various types of things
like that.
And that shows
you the structure.
So this is a very
nice structure.
We can zoom in here.
And then you see-- and more
struct-- sub-structures
emerge here.
What's that one?
Let me take a look.
Here is this.
United States, very
popular-- dense.
You see that very dense thing,
like the United States here.
Who's this?
This is probably America
or something like that.
United Nations Security
Council, very popular.
Oh-- the organizations here.
Yeah, we don't have so many of
them, it's the most popular.
So you can just get this feel
of the data, very powerful.
Because often,
for the most part,
when you work with your
customer, and you do this,
you can be just about 100%
sure you're the first person
to actually get a view.
A high level view of the
overall structure of the data,
in a very powerful perspective.
Because they simply just
don't have a way to do this.
And using the sparse matrix is
a way to just review the data.
It's very, very powerful.
All right.
So let's get rid of that.
So we did the
entity-entity graph.
Again, what we do
is just whenever
we take an incidence
matrix, and we sort of
square it, or correlate it.
Then the result is an
adjacency matrix, or graph
between those two things.
So then adjacency
matrices are a projection
from the incidence matrix.
We've lost some
information, we've
always thrown away some
information in doing that.
But often, that's exactly
what we want to do.
You want to project it
down into a subspace
that we find more interesting.
Something else that we
can do, is let's just look
at the people beginning with J.
All right.
So I'm going to
just get-- create
a little starts
with entity range
here with our
starts with command.
I can pass that into it here,
to grid just the records that
have the entity p.
And I'm going to do
the correlation of them
using this pedigree preserving
matrix multiply that we have.
This very special one.
So we'll go take a look at that.
And that will explain what I
mean by pedigree preserving.
So we go here.
So again, this shows you all
the people that appear together,
beginning with the
name J. And it's
of course again,
symmetric matrix.
Distance diagonal.
You click on, it tells you.
So Jennifer Hurley
and James Harvey
appeared in this
document together.
So when we do that
special matrix multiply,
it doesn't preserve the values
in the normal matrix multiply
sense.
Instead, it preserves the label
of the common dimension that's
eliminated.
So when we do matrix multiply,
you're limiting dimension.
We now take that
common intersection
and throw that in the value.
So you can now say, Jennifer
Hurley, James Harvey
were connected by this document.
And so very powerful
tool for doing that.
You notice, I
restricted it to J.
Why did I do-- why didn't
just I do the whole thing?
Well, you see this
dense diagonal here.
If you had a very popular
person, look at all the
hits we're going to get when
we correlated with itself.
OK.
This becomes a
performance bottleneck
when we start creating
enormously long values.
And so we always
have to be careful
when we do these pedigree
preserving correlations.
If it's calculating
one set with another,
we're not have a dense diagonal.
It's going to be fine.
But if we're correlating
something with itself,
we always have to
be on the lookout
that we might be creating
these dense diagonals.
In which case, we
could have an issue
that we might create a
very, very large value.
And the fact of the
matter is, the way
we sort the strains is we
convert the list to a dense car
matrix.
And then call the
MATLAB sort routine.
It's the only way
we can sort it.
And so the width of that matrix
is the length of the longest
string in the list.
So they're all about the
same length, it's fine.
But if you have
mostly things that
are 20 characters, and
then you have something
that's 2,000 characters long.
And you create 100,000
by 2,000 matrix,
you've just consumed
an awful lot of memory.
And sorting that and all
that just-- so whenever
people say it's slow or
they run out of memory,
it's almost always
because they're creating,
they have a string
list and we're trying
to manipulate it by sorting.
And one of the values in that
string is just extremely long.
So that's just a little caveat.
A very powerful
technique, you have
to watch out for this diagonal.
And there's ways
to work around it,
that are usually data specific.
But again a very
powerful-- this pedigree
preserving correlation,
something that usually people
want.
And especially since
we almost usually store
just like a one in the
value, we're not really
throwing away any information.
Sometimes we want it,
because we want to count
how many times those happen.
If we didn't do the
pedigree preserving,
the catkey [INAUDIBLE],
then we would have
gotten a value of three here.
And so we could have counted.
It would have told us.
Sometimes we do them both.
One that gives us the count,
one that gives us the pedigree.
And just store them both.
There's different things
that we want-- that we
do with one versus the other.
So again, having fun with
the different types of matrix
multiplies that we can do in
the space of associative arrays.
All right.
We're running out of time here,
but I think we're almost done.
So let me just see here.
Then we did the
document-document correlation,
so this is the square out,
which is e times e transpose.
And we'll just take
a quick look at that.
So again, here we
are for your four.
This just shows us which
documents are closely related
to each other.
Which documents have a
lot of common entities.
So this just says here that
these two documents share-- had
one common entity with them.
Other ones.
Just clicking around here, not
having a lot of luck finding
one that's got a lot in it.
So maybe around here, nope.
No.
Well certainly if I click
on the diagonal, nope.
Wow.
Basically pretty sparse,
sparse correlations
between these documents.
So all right.
And I think we'll go
now to the last example.
Is there a last example?
Yes.
One-- one last one.
Yay.
[INAUDIBLE]
All right.
So now we'll do-- the
stuff I showed you
so far is pretty easy stuff.
Pretty sophisticated by
a lot of the standards
are out there, in
terms being able to do
sums, and histograms,
and basic correlations.
That's often significantly
beyond what is just
sort of the run of the
mill, which you'll just
run in to if you just go into
a place doing basic analysis.
So again we load it.
We convert everything
to numeric.
We've now squared it.
So we created the graph.
Now I want to get rid of
that annoying diagonal,
so I got the diagonal out.
So just so you
know, all I did is
I take-- I know it's a square,
so I can do certain things
without worrying.
So I can basically take
the adjacency matrix,
that just going to be a
regular MATLAB sparse matrix.
I can now do-- take
the diagonal back.
And since it's a square,
I can just take those two,
subtract them from each
other, and just insert it
back in without any harm done.
Knowing it's like look, I took
a square adjacency matrix out,
did some manipulation.
Stuff it back in.
The dimensions are the same.
You know, it should be OK.
I might have an issue that I may
have introduced an empty row,
or an empty column, you know.
Which could cause me
a little problems.
I'm now going to get
the triples of that,
because I want to
normalize the values here.
So I'm going to get the--
the diagonals showed me
how many counts are
in each document.
So I want to normalize
any entities in a document
because sometimes you'll
get a document that's like,
and here's a list of
every single country that
participated in this UN meeting.
And it'll have a hundred
and something countries.
So a country appearing
in that document
is not such a big deal,
because all the countries
appear in that document.
So this allows us to do that.
If we want to do a correlation,
we take the actual value
and then divide
it by the minimum.
The least documented would
be the maximum number
of hits you could get
in the correlation.
You can do multi-facet queries.
So we want do location
against all people.
And so here's a more
complicated query which says,
find me all people that
appeared more than four times,
and with a probability greater
than 0.3, and with respect
to the New York.
So here's New York, and
all these different people
who are basically--
these are people
that appeared with New York,
and almost exclusively appeared
with New York.
So.
So John Kennedy, so
this is his son that
was still alive at that time.
Was very popular in the news.
And so let's focus on him.
So let's get John Kennedy,
let's get his neighborhood.
So we can go into his-- get
all the people other people who
appeared in documents
with John Kennedy,
and we can plot that
neighborhood, and you go here.
This is his neighborhood.
There's John Kennedy.
His rows and columns.
And then these are all the other
people that appeared with him.
You see this dense
row and column.
And then these are what
are called the triangles.
So these are other people who
appeared in documents together,
you know.
So George Bush and
Jim Wright appeared
in a document together, but not
necessarily with John Kennedy.
And we can actually
find those people
by just doing this
basic arithmetic here.
And this shows us
all the triangles,
all the other people also
appeared in documents together,
who appeared with John Kennedy.
And so that's what you asked.
So with that, we will-- we're
running a little bit late here,
so we will wrap it up.
And again, encourage you
to go into your code,
and run these
examples and try out.
And this should give you
the first sense really kind
of working with some real
data, and playing with stuff.
So.
Thank you very much.